but before we delve really deeply into
the angle reaction we can ask this
opinion we have a winner of today's
round alex lenderman defeating camille
dragoon
alex uh first of all congratulations on
your victory that is your first victory
of the event kind of a difficult event
for you up to this point what does this
victory mean for you
um well it's just nice to play a good
game um because
the first four games were really not
enjoyable for me like i was defending
every game the positions were not
enjoyable
so i decided yesterday to try to play
something more interesting
uh something new for me
um
okay it's even though i lost the game
okay it's a more enjoyable game than the
previous ones so i wasn't that unhappy
because okay it's there are definitely
worse things right now happening in the
world than just losing a chess game
so yeah i was trying to go into the game
with a positive mindset like the four
round tournament completely from from
from scratch
and uh yeah just focused on playing a
good game getting a position i was
relatively comfortable with and
going for a fight well let's uh look at
the game and see where do you feel like
you're taking over the initiative
because it felt like quite a balanced
let's say opening phase of the game but
after that you at some point took uh
took full control of it i guess i was a
little bit surprised that he gave me the
d5 pawn okay it's uh i knew i had some
initiative
yes
uh okay i was hoping that i have some
play on the king's side but
okay bishop c8 do you feel like he just
missed the rook takes d5 no of course he
it was a sacrifice i don't think it's a
blunder but i guess he thought that the
attack is very strong and he wanted to
go bishop five exchange the bishops and
uh
goku e6 queen g6 or something like that
but the problem with the move like
bishop c8 here is that when i take the
pawn on d5 i can easily go e4 and now my
problem bishop on c1 is not a problem
anymore i was a bit um
skeptical about my attack because sake
had a bad bishop on c1 so for that
reason i wasn't sure how good my attack
will be but i guess yeah he thought it
was going to be going to be very strong
but at the same time once i took the
pawn on d5 it just became so easy for me
to play right
all right so it seemed that after this
is
it's not just about the pawn right it's
about the central control you got here
yeah yeah this
and also activating my bishop right on
right one yeah it went from c1 and now
it's actually attacking the pawns from
being very good piece now all of a
sudden right so that's
that was very helpful so that forces the
transition into because for example for
example yesterday i also lost because i
had this bad bishop on c1 and i was
thinking oh no no not again but but then
he gave me the d5 pawn so i was kind of
happy at least i knew that
i could play this very safe position you
also played a bishop end game against
hans neiman so it seems like the bishops
are definitely a big uh playing a big
role in this story that was a much more
unpleasant end game i have to say than
this one
although it turns out i was holding a
draw if i didn't step into that zoox
wing which i completely missed
yeah well alex uh congratulations on
this victory and we're looking forward
to see you in the rest of your games
thank you thank you alex certainly
always a fighting